boa tarde
jornalista não sabe falar sem papel na
mão então fez me desculpe pelas
anotações é bom
meu nome é adriana carranca eu sou
jornalista e escritora eu conto
histórias e é sobre isso sobre o poder
de contar histórias que eu gostaria de
falar hoje com vocês as histórias elas
ficam para a eternidade
elas é quando não há mais memória elas
escrevem na verdade a nossa existência
histórias que não são contadas é como se
nunca existe sem elas são esquecidas com
o tempo quando não há não houver mais
memória a primeira experiência primeiro
contato que eu tive com a importância de
contar histórias
foi no sudão do sul num campo de
refugiados na fronteira de uganda é era
noite estava tudo muito escuro com uma
completa escuridão e ouvir a distância
eu tinha ido ao campo para saber como
eles viviam naquela situação à noite e
eu ouvi a distância uma música e me
aproximei núncio seguir enquanto eu não
chegasse perto daquela música e soubesse
o que estava acontecendo
e então eu descobri que eles contavam
histórias eram refugiados tinham fugido
é da guerra deixando tudo para trás suas
casas roupas objetos fotografias ea
única coisa que restava eles era memória
e ele estavam então tentado compartilhar
essa memória os adultos com as crianças
para poder continuar existindo sem isso
é como se eles não fizessem parte da
nossa história nós só sabemos do passado
através das histórias que nós contamos e
registramos de alguma forma
é a vida de cada um de nós aqui é uma
história de não ficção e é um trecho da
narrativa da nossa existência
a questão então que se coloca quais
histórias contar com que histórias nós
estamos construindo a narrativa da nossa
existência
eu vou contar um pouquinho da minha
história em busca de histórias dos
outros ao redor do mundo
essa história começou quando eu ganhei
uma bolsa de estudos pra pra ir para
londres e na minha classe nos anos 60
alunos de 45 países a minha melhor amiga
uma egípcia e nas férias de primavera
ela nos convidou pra ir pra passar as
férias com ela no egito porque havia a
família dela havia destacado três
pretendentes entre os quais ela deveria
escolher um para se casar
então nós fomos as três amigas
o eucanaã a sida católica é não não
praticante que decide não tem religião
para poder escrever sobre as religiões é
com maior isenção a geraldine que é uma
filipina protestante adílio quer uma
judia canadense pra ajudar a dynamo sul
humana egípcia escolher um marido e
quando os meninos jovens estão
cortejando as meninas no egito eles
paparicam as amigas então foi a melhor
viagem que a gente já fez hoje ganhou
presentes nós só não andar de barco no
rio nilo gente recebia flores todos os
dias mas o que mais me marcou naquela
viagem foi que quando a gente voltava
para o quarto
nós quatro reunidas ali nós éramos só
quatro meninas conversando sobre o que
meninas e meninos conversam no mundo
inteiro sobre amor amizade família
futuro o trabalho escola universidade
exceto para ali não havia judia católica
protestante não havia a muçulmana não
havia egípcia brasileira
nós existe absolutamente nada que nos
diferenciar se e eu comecei a me
perguntar se isso era verdade se a
narrativa que a gente ouve de certos
lugares
ela não é ela não é a narrativa completa
da realidade que acontece no solo no
campo
então eu voltei para o egito depois para
o casamento da dina ela não se casou com
nenhum daqueles três casou com outro que
ela conheceu no sambão em londres
e quando eu fui para o casamento da da
dina
essa é a geraldine na primeira a
primeira imagem que eu tive da
hostilidade do ódio entre a área bisa e
e judeus foi essa imagem da dessa
amizade entre as duas então pra mim
nunca houve essa inimizade porque a
minha primeira percepção desse conflito
foi através da amizade é quando foi dito
que o casamento da dina decidir de lá
pelo irã
e eu tinha a imagem de que eu encontrar
um país é destruído pela guerra
empobrecido um país é economicamente
destruído por sanções econômicas isolado
mulheres oprimidas e eu é eu fiz uma
escala nos emirados árabes para comprar
um véu porque é obrigatório no irã
o uso do véu quando você entra no espaço
aéreo iraniano você é o comissário de
bordo te avisa pra colocar é o recebe as
aves as mulheres porque a lei no país
então eu fui ao shopping nessa escala
para pedir ajuda as meninas pra eu
comprar um véu este mês para um café
porque eu queria saber como é que era
viver como é que era ser essas mulheres
cuja imagem eu tinha de descer em
mulheres oprimidos na e mas antes dá
nesse café antes da gente começar a
conversar com uma das meninas essa que
está de óculos que é uma designer de
é a bahia é de 10 dessas roupas pretas
né do nicab é ela falou não queria fazer
uma pergunta é verdade que as
brasileiras fazem muitas plásticas
ele é verdade é porque ela falou nossa
que o pressão isso é que a opressão
feminina você se obrigada a se submeter
a cirurgias a uma cirurgia pra poder
circular e e se aceita na sociedade
então pra mim o que eu via como a
pressão pra ela pra ela era a
libertadores é a forma como que ela se
vestia era uma forma de liberdade porque
sobre o nicab ela podia ser quem ela
quisesse
e aí eu percebi que a narrativa que a
gente contava dessas regiões e dessas
mulheres
ignoravam uma parte importante da
narrativa que era a visão delas próprias
e de como elas vêem o mundo é bom de lá
eu fui então pelo irã e eu cheguei no
irã
vestida com o nicab com toda aquela
bagagem é que eu tinha sobre o irã do
que eu achava que encontrará no irã e eu
fui recebida no aeroporto tinha marcado
com a minha tradutora e à distância eu
avistei uma menina de calça jeans
all-star cor de rosa uma batinha
colorida e o véu que mal cobrir o cabelo
e quando me aproximei olhou pra mim e
falou mas o que você está fazendo
vestida desse jeito nós iríamos à
iraniana somos muito modernas e nós
fomos para o centro de teerã no carro
dela ela dirigindo ouvindo funk iraniano
e aí eu percebi que também no irã
a narrativa que eu ouvia do irã não era
completa no irã conheci mulheres
incríveis que se vestem das mais
diferentes formas
a advogada cineastas estudantes ela eu
descobri que elas são os ocupam 70% das
vagas nas universidades 50 por cento da
força de trabalho a primeira mulher a
ganhar o nobel da paz é uma iraniana
primeira o nobel da paz pelo irã vêm das
mãos de uma mulher shirin ebadi
só que essas histórias elas não cabiam
elas não se encaixavam na narrativa da
época sobre a na época se falava muito
do programa nuclear iraniano então só as
histórias de violência se encaixavam
realmente nessa narrativa e as outras
histórias eram ignorados
eu fui então tentar descobrir outras
histórias de outros lugares e descobrir
se realmente a narrativa desses lugares
não estava completa então de lá é eu fui
pro feminino estão é as narrativas têm
sido muito usadas para nos fazer apoiar
é ofensiva os militares então quem não
se lembra do iraque
daça armas de destruição em massa no
iraque nós acreditamos naquilo e
apoiamos a maioria dos americanos na
época apoiou a guerra no iraque porque
foi é exposta uma narrativa de que não
irá que havia armas de destruição em
massa ou mesmo não com relação às afegãs
as mulheres sobre as burcas que a gente
deveria salvar por uma ação militar
e eu fui pro feminino estão e descobrir
sobre essas burcas histórias também
então incríveis quanto tinha descoberto
no irã
você tem uma série de questões pelas
quais elas estão lutando elas lutam por
seus direitos é o governo tenta
oprimirás tenta limitar o seu papel na
sociedade
mas ouvi uma frase
é muito importante que eu ouvi da shirin
ebadi que a nobel da paz iraniana
quando eu fui entrevistá lá ela me
recebeu com o véu e como eu sabia que
ela defendia a liberdade feminina eu
perguntei a ela chegue porque você está
usando o véu mesmo dentro de casa com a
sua história de defesa da liberdade ela
foi porque eu não defendo não usar o véu
eu defendo a liberdade da escolha
mesmo que seja para escolher usar o
hijab e se eu tivesse essa liberdade eu
escolheria usá lo e aí eu percebi que o
que o aquilo pelo que ela luta é o
aquilo pelo que todos nós lutamos não há
diferença entre nós mulheres e homens
todos nós lutamos pelo direito de ter
liberdade de escolha
então as afegãs também lutam por isso e
você tem mulheres começa a professora
que educou 150 meninas dentro da sua
casa secretamente durante o regime do
taliban
você tem essa deputada a primeira mulher
a concorrer à presidência do afeganistão
a editora da primeira revista feminina
do afeganistão a comandante da pre do 1º
batalhão feminino do afeganistão que
está tentando humanizar mais ações
militares
ela tem um blog de poesia ela estava
para se casar
nas semanas seguintes com um jovem dez
anos mais novo do que ela de outra etnia
e de uma patente inferior a ela no
exército que tinha se apaixonado por ela
ler as poesias que ela escrevia sem
saber que ela era uma comandante do
exército e eles iam se casar quebrando
todos os tabus possíveis existentes no
afeganistão a chama se a primeira
grafiteiro de cabul que está
redesenhando os muros destruídos pela
guerra com a sua arte
a primeira boxeadora afegã a participar
de um campeonato mundial ela luta -
mesmo estádio em que as mulheres antes
eram julgadas e condenadas muitas vezes
ao apedrejamento e ela escolheu lutar
nesse ginásio como uma forma de
resistência pacífica de mostrar
a luta dessa nova geração é outra eu
tive eu encontrei as mesmas histórias eu
poderia ficar aqui dias falando no
paquistão indonésia turquia israel gaza
ea cisjordânia no congo sudão áfrica do
sul etiópia méxico haiti
todos esses lugares essas histórias
existem só que o que acontece é que
muitas vezes elas são invisíveis e o
problema de não dá espaço a narrativa
para histórias pacíficas e preços atores
a não-violentos sido só os atores que
usam da violência domina a narrativa o
que é com a mensagem que a gente porque
a gente manda para aqueles que tentam
mudar as coisas através de acções
não-violentas é de que o carro único
caminho possível é ter uma arma na mão
é essa mensagem que a gente diz pra eles
se essas histórias pacíficas não têm voz
não tem espaço não causam nenhuma
pressão é e portanto nenhuma reação eles
se cansam de tentar mudar as coisas
através de acções não violentas e muitos
deles passam a ter ações violentas
nós vivemos hoje uma luta de narrativas
essa é a grande guerra que nós vivemos
no mundo hoje
as histórias que nós contamos tenham
impacto direto e concreto na realidade
isso têm sido estudados estudado por
vários cientistas o haiti tem um
departamento exclusivo para estudar
correlação entre como nosso cérebro
funciona quando exposto a diferentes
narrativas e como isso pode impulsionar
a violência
emily bruno é um professor do mit que
cuida desse departamento
os pesquisadores já tinham descoberto
por exemplo que quando você é ler sobre
o sofrimento de outras pessoas
uma área
seu cérebro é ativada e é a mesma área
de quando você está sofrendo aquela dor
você mesma conclusão que a que se chega
é que nós todos somos capazes de
desenvolver empatia nós sentimos a dor
do outro mas os pesquisadores
descobriram também que isso só é verdade
quando é o objecto da violência nos efe
ou seja só quando nós nos relacionamos
com aquela vítima da violência é que ela
causa essa relação de empatia na gente
isso explica por exemplo porque quando
existem atentados em nova york ou em
paris
a reação a nossa reação a reação mundial
e na internet também é muito maior do
que por exemplo um atentado na nigéria
porque é mais pré mas nós nos sentimos
nos colocamos mais no lugar das pessoas
que estão na frança ou nos estados
unidos porque talvez nós visitamos mais
esses lugares e nós pouco ouvimos falar
sobre a nigéria nigéria não tem espaço
na narrativa que está sendo escrita hoje
e portanto a nigéria nos é um lugar
muito pouco familiar e age e eficiente
ficar mente é nosso cérebro não reagir à
violência sofrida por pessoas é na
nigéria os pesquisadores também
descobriram que há mesmo quando a gente
é capaz de desenvolver a empatia existe
uma reação contrária que é você
desenvolve a empatia por um grupo e isso
faz com que você apoia a violência
inconscientemente de outro grupo em
todos os filmes a gente está sempre
torcendo para o banco o mocinho contra
os bandidos mesmo que o mocinho pratique
atos de violência também
então isso acaba é perpetuando a
violência é o que os pesquisadores
chamam de guerra pe da empatia falha da
empatia uma falha no sistema de empatia
é a resposta é do nosso cérebro ela só é
diferente quando nós somos expostos aí
histórias positivas histórias em que
existem existe o sofrimento mas o foco
da história é uma ação positiva que está
conseguindo transformar aquela situação
nesse caso e só nesse caso a reação do
nosso cérebro é de conforto e de é
altruísmo é isso isso tem um impacto na
gente é no desejo de ajudar e contribuir
com aquela mudança que está sendo
mostrada e aqui reside precisamente o
poder de contar histórias
o poder que hoje está na mão nas mãos de
todos nós porque hoje todos vocês podem
contar histórias na sua timeline
ao compartilhar ou a disseminar o
disseminar informação
os pesquisadores no entanto também
descobriram que na internet nós também
temos uma tendência maior a compartilhar
só aquilo que nos é familiar
nós temos só os nossos amigos na nossa
nas nossas redes sociais nós só é
compartilhamos aquilo ao pensamento de
pessoas que são parecidas com a gente
isso no lugar de desenvolver a empatia
aumentar as distâncias reforça as
diferenças está provocando um declínio
da nossa capacidade de desenvolver
empatia é pelo outro isso foi uma
pesquisa também feita é entre até 2009
que trabalhou esse impacto da internet
então se eu puder deixar uma mensagem
hoje pra vocês eu diria que lembrem se
de que nós estamos escrevendo juntos a
narrativa da nossa existência é ao invés
de promover o ódio ea violência
compartilhem ações pacíficas e exemplos
positivos que inspiram e transformam ao
invés de destacar aquilo que nos
distancia vamos mostrar aquilo que nos
aproxima e que nos torna
iguais como humanos é e assim é que nós
vamos construir juntos uma narrativa
pacífica de um mundo melhor para todos
obrigado
[Aplausos]